what a day you've had you were across
the country earlier today are you okay
yeah like what time is it I don't even
know what day it is
don't even tell me a date I have no idea
we're like for four days past the World
Cup that's all I know I mean you were in
Europe like what time zone are you in
you know yeah I mean I have no idea I
think it's like 6:00 a.m. in France
right now so running on fumes but I mean
it's not hard when you have this in your
hand and I mean look you go from New
York and all that cheering and all that
celebrating and then you got to get glam
yeah I was this night emotional for you
was it exciting what was going through
your mind out on that stage just
excitement and also just feeling proud
to have like my family and attendance as
well they like I always say like they're
on vacation when I'm playing but they're
really not like they're on this roller
coaster with us and like every four days
we play a game and like it's so
exhausting and it takes everything out
of me and then we need to pick it back
up and do it four days later in a World
Cup seven times in a row and like my
families along along the right too so I
think tonight we're just like enjoying
enjoy I mean you guys have been fighting
to go out and freaking win the World Cup
for us but also fight for women and
fight for equal pay and you had a lot of
cheerleaders tonight Billie Jean was
here you know so many people how does
that feel for you to feel that support
from other female athletes
it's incredible these are the women that
really paved the way and so for us to
kind of fall in the footsteps and kind
of now bare some of that responsibility
and take that with pride it means a lot
so yeah she was she was the first and
miss a word for you I mean I you got to
take this moment in a little bit are you
in shock are you feeling I'm feeling
good yeah I guess I'm still a little
like taking it in a little bit but
obviously it's an incredible award and
there's been so many amazing women that
I have watched go on the stage and get
this award as I've been to many ESPYs
before so it's great to know be that
woman and I mean you guys have had a lot
to say over the past couple months
you've had a lot to say in the face of
some criticism what did you want to say
with your speech tonight so I wanted to
say that we need to invest in women and
when you've invested in women you see
the return on it the World Cup was a
perfect example of it of the fact that
yes I know we give you a soccer and
extremely hard time
but you have to give them credit for
investing in this team over the course
of the last 20 years and you could see
that in the World Cup how dominant we
were and teams that weren't so dominant
but have the potential don't have the
investment from their country from their
Federation from from the people who
might now respect to the sport as much
so I think investing in women's sports
is so crucial how do you feel about how
everything went in New York today you
guys had so many people cheering for you
rightfully so but you know there there
is still things hanging over your head
of the cause that you're fighting for
yeah I think that today we were just
enjoying actually the last couple days
we were enjoying it it's not without
some tough questions of course which
we're willing to face head-on but this
morning we were just overwhelmed with
the support and you know and when you're
in France for a month
playing for a World Cup you don't
realize the impacts that we have on this
country over a short period of time and
the amount of eyes that are watching so
we got a glimpse of that this morning
and it was quite incredible we were
talking earlier about everything megan's
had to say too about how awesome it was
to hear say this team has new black
girls white girls straight girls gay
girls and how amazing that it was like
is she like a rapper no she's like
rhyming and all this and like the best
public speaker ever I'm like okay you
have like a job anywhere you want after
that speech like for her to be able to
say that you know that's women's
different sexualities or not something
they could always talk about you know
and how have you guys you know kind of
soak that in as a team that like you've
paved the way in so many ways yeah I
think we're all about inclusivity and I
think that we say that every single day
I think we walk the walk and Meghan's a
prime example of someone who is willing
to stand up for what she believes in and
and speak her mind on it and I think
that that's kind of giving us a little
motivation and courage to do to do the
same on the team so it's pretty great to
have her as a teammate
she's been incredible and she's I'm so
happy to have her on my side and I saw a
tweet that I can't stop thinking about a
guy from the ringer tweeted the women's
soccer team said we're gonna turn down
an invite from the White House then they
went and won the World Cup that's the
biggest flex ever I mean if you guys
talked about that anymore how are you
feeling as you as you move forward after
New York
we've talked a little bit about it but
it's kind of been a whirlwind of a
couple of days we really need to sit
down and talk more about it and have a
real discussion about it because of
course the White House is more than just
one person but at the same time the one
person you know that is the most
important person doesn't doesn't agree
on a lot of things that we are and who
and what we really talk about and and
who we are so I think that's really
difficult so I think we'll have to talk
about it for now we're just enjoying and
celebrating and obviously in the next
couple of weeks there'll be some tough
decisions to make have you heard from
him at all no we haven't got a formal
invitation just a tweet tweet I got to
tell you all night long we've been
having people do the tea sip I never
okay I like this can you give it to us
one more time we got to get it from the
expert I mean it's better with champagne
but I'll do it with the trophy fine
[Music]